hello I'm Brett Goldstein
hello I'm taheed Jamal I am Brendan hunt
I am Hannah waddingham
and I'm Jason Sudeikis and today we are
taking the BuzzFeed quiz which Ted lasso
character are you because we are members
of the cast of Ted lasso
[Music]
all right first what's a quality you
look for in a best friend honesty sense
of humor kindness sense of adventure
supportiveness or optimism I chose sense
of humor
because I think
because I like funny people but Jason
wouldn't you say yes you look for a
sense of humor in basically everyone you
associate with so I might I'm gonna go
optimism I'm similar but I'm going for
supportiveness when I need to be held I
need to be held yeah
that's why we're back
I went for honesty because I like having
people around me that tell me how it is
don't blow smoke up my
yep I exclusively like friends who will
like smoke up my
oh I picked a sense of humor as well
because although it's important to have
kindness and optimism
I agree with everything you've said and
I'm vaguely regretting the choice choose
a Ted lasso character to trust with a
secret we have Higgins
um Flo Collins that was the last name
yeah Phil Collins who knew best friends
for years AKA sassy yeah sassy pants
Jamie tart Phoebe Danny Rojas Dr Sharon
Fieldstone feel free to go why can I say
you I definitely wouldn't trust with the
secret to be assassinated I would
probably go for Phoebe she's such a
little love the older soul
I feel like we all try and have selfies
with her yeah yeah she just always
fixing the lighting yeah I gotta go Dr
Fieldstone yeah she uttered an oath yeah
when she had that bike crash she's just
letting it fly yeah
I went Dr Sharon too
yeah he's been there he's done it like
in these darker days of season Once
Phoebe she might tell Roy but I don't
want to put secrets into it into a child
when you put it like that you know it
won't hurt to be free
I mean sassy is a child psychologist and
not all of us were like we would never
he's a song of Matt this is my choose a
song to belt out a karaoke anti-hero by
Taylor Swift I want to dance with
somebody by Whitney Houston about damn
time by lizzo karaoke absolutely not Mr
Brightside by The Killers Dancing Queen
by Abba I read them in the wrong order
clearly uh I can't go with uh anti-hero
because T Swift and I had a thing and I
feel like that one's about me
luckily the people that read BuzzFeed
don't care about stuff like that I think
I'm gonna go with Mr Brightside and
overlooked quality for a uh for a
karaoke song uh no solos you know we're
not we're not doing the like 34 measures
here I think I'm going to Whitney I want
to dance with somebody yeah ambitious I
always start out fresh with Whitney and
then think well this is a song Too Far
absolutely not I hate karaoke but I do
love watching Brendan do karaoke so I
will and my son yeah I would hand my
song to him and I would choose about
damn time because he would
yeah hey there's no wait you don't know
I can't bear it no the amount of time
I've seen that arm get twisted very
easily
choose an actor to star in a movie with
Paul Rudd Zendaya Dwayne The Rock
Johnson Jennifer Coolidge Pedro Pascal
Winona Ryder
category I think I'd have to go Paul
Rudd because I'd want him to do fake
piano I love him it's very nearly a six
week tie but I'm gonna go with Winona
because she's the one who has been
closer to my heart for the longest time
forever yeah yeah I'm going Zendaya I
think she's like one of the most
talented people on the planet like she's
she's yeah she's too hard yeah I wanted
to guys in there but you've taken it
yeah all right I'm going Zendaya because
she's uh she works a lot man if she has
time for it I would probably go win on a
writer as well and do a sequel to
Reality Bites called reality bit aging
Mr Stiller
choose an iconic sports movie to watch
tonight oh God read I Tonya
A League of Their Own Friday Night
Lights Space Jam space basketball A
League of Their Own for me yeah
[Laughter]
I need to thank you guys for this whole
Ted lasso shebang yep because um I met
Gina Davis in the summer in the ladies
lose and she went hello Hannah I love
your work and I went
you know I didn't know that yeah that's
awesome yeah so you were on the toilet
when that happened and finally picked
something important from Ted lasso the
believe sign biscuits with the boss the
Crown and Anchor keeley's Vanity Fair
photo shoot AFC Richmond or Ted's
mustache
a greyhound I'm going to
answer yeah to love them yeah I'm
literally Pablo's dogs like I go
keeley's fancy Fair shoot you know I'm
gonna go Crown and Anchor I I think it's
good to have a place go
[Applause]
there you go so yeah they nailed it
thank you BuzzFeed Apple TV Plus
fun
[Music]